- contest arena's Petra is here with the
new Skoda Kodiak it's named after a type
of brown bear that inhabits the islands
of the Kodiak archipelago in Alaska seed
from the site it does resemble the
elongated silhouette of a bear but is it
the top predator of the urban jungle or
just a teddy bear let's find out that's
in your dad olive
the Kodiak offers a choice of five
engines three gasoline and two diesel
we're testing the weaker diesel engine
the 2-liter TDI with 110 kilowatts of
power this model also has permanent
all-wheel drive and 7-speed dual-clutch
transmission the bear can leap from zero
to 100 kilometers an hour in 9.8 seconds
front assist with city emergency brake
and pedestrian protection is standard
the function initiates braking
automatically to make city driving safer
a maneuver assist minimizes the risk of
collision while reversing the system
area view is a new addition for Skoda it
offers virtual displays of the area
around the vehicle making it easier to
drive in confusing situations or rough
terrain
[Music]
from the front the bear looks tough but
not aggressive as a first for Skoda
standard equipment includes LED lights
that look like a work of art a row of
LEDs along the bottom of the raked
headlights work as indicators as well as
daytime running lights
[Music]
and in case you forgot your umbrella
there's one stored in the driver's side
door pop outdoor protectors mean no more
chipped edges
[Music]
Dina says the van like design perfectly
accommodates a third seeding row but the
use of space is flexible you can get
more legroom by moving the second row up
to 18 centimeters lengthwise you can
also change the angle of the backrests
Dylan and M Ventura and lon
[Music]
as far as our tester is concerned adults
would have enough space here in the back
row
even with the backrest up in the middle
the only downside is you can't change
the angle of the backrest here no matter
which of trim lines you choose the third
seating row costs an extra 750 euros our
test vehicle is outfitted with on
top-of-the-range style option that has a
great feel and the workmanship is of the
highest quality in Germany the price of
our test model starts at just under
40,000 euros but with fewer features and
a smaller engine you can get a Kodiak
for a little over 26,000
[Music]
the third row of seats fold down easily
when they're not in use
[Music]
not to FEMA says that while SUVs have
never been the most fuel-efficient
option the makers are trying to keep it
economical with efficient engines and
lightweight construction in addition the
kodiak has six different driving modes
so you can choose the profile that suits
best that way the driver can decide if
they want to experience the bears wild
side or if they prefer a fuel-efficient
and resource oriented form of transport
while in sport mode the Kodiak delivers
high performance and top speeds an eco
mode it activates the freewheel function
as soon as the driver takes their foot
off the pedal when traveling over 20
kilometers an hour
the engine is uncoupled from the gearbox
and kicks into coasting mode
[Music]
[Applause]
matanzima says that at four point seven
meters that kodiak is a substantial car
but was seating for seven people it's a
good option for families with city
driving there is of course the challenge
of being able to find a big enough
parking space but if this is a car that
suits your needs then the Skoda Kodiak
presents great value for money as far as
this class of vehicle goes internal
space lessons forehead nose and love
hats our classroom and aboard
[Music]
you